i think you're pretty familiar with the
idea of matrix vector products what i
want to do is i in this video is show
you that taking a
a product of a vector with a matrix is
equivalent to a transformation it's
actually a linear transformation so let
me let's say we have some
matrix a
and let's say that its terms are or its
columns are
v1
their vector column vectors v2
all the way to vn so this guy has n
columns let's see has m rows so it's an
m
by n
matrix and let's say i define some
transformation
let's say i define some transformation
let's say my transformation goes from
r n
goes from rn
to r
m this is the domain i can take any
vector in rn and it will map it to some
vector in rm and i define my
transformation so t of
x where this is some vector in rn is
equal to
a
my this this this is this a let me write
it in this color right here it should be
bolded i kind of get careless sometimes
with the bolding but big bold a times
the vector x so the first thing you
might say sal g this you know this this
transformation looks very odd relative
to how we've been defining
transformations or functions so far so
the first thing we have to just
feel comfortable with is the idea that
this is a transformation so what are we
doing we're taking something from rn and
then what does ax produce
what does ax produce and we can
we can
ax if we write ax like this if this is x
where it's x1 x2 it's going to have n
terms because it's an n it's an rn
this can be rewritten as
x1 times v1 plus x2 times v2 all the way
to x
n times vn so it's going to be a sum of
a bunch of of these column vectors and
each of these column vectors v1
2
all the way to v n
what set are they members of well this
is an m by n matrix so they're going to
have m the the matrix has m rows or each
of these column vectors will have m
entries so all of these guys are members
of rm so if i just take a linear
combination of all of these guys i'm
going to get another member of rm
so this guy right here is going to be a
member of rm another vector so clearly
by multiplying my vector x times a i'm
mapping i'm creating a mapping
from
our
rn
and let me pick another color
2
2 rm and i'm saying it in very general
terms maybe n is 3 maybe m is 5 who
knows but i'm saying in very general
terms and so if this is a particular
instance a particular member of set rn
so it's that vector our transformation
or our function is going to map it
to this guy right here and this guy will
be a member of rm and we could call him
ax or maybe if we said ax equal b we
could call him the vector b whatever but
this is our transformation mapping so
this does fit our our our kind of
definition or our our
terminology for a function or a
transformation as a mapping from one set
to another but still might not be
satisfying because you know everything
we saw before looked kind of like this
you know we if we had a transformation i
would write it like you know the
transformation of i would write you know
x1 and x2
and
x n is equal to and i'd write and i'd
write
i'd write a bunch of i'd write m terms
here and commas and you're like you know
how does this relate to that and to do
that i'll do a specific example so let's
say that i had the matrix
let's say that i have the matrix let me
do a different letter let's say i have
my matrix b
and it is a fairly simple matrix let's
say 2 minus 1
3
and 4.
and i define some transformation
so i define some transformation so i
define some transformation t and it goes
from r 2
to
r 2
r 2 and i define t t of some vector x
is equal to
this matrix
b
times that vector x now what would that
equal
well the matrix is right there
it's let me write it in purple 2 minus 1
3 and 4
times
x x1 x2
and so what does this equal
well this equals another vector it
equals a vector in the codomain r2 where
the first term is 2 times x1 i'm just
doing the definition of matrix vector
multiplication 2 times x1 to x1
plus -1 times x2 or minus
x2 that's that row times our vector and
then the second row times that vector we
get
3 times x1
3 times x1
plus 4 times x2 plus 4 times x 2.
so this is what we might be more
familiar with and i could write i could
rewrite this transformation i could
rewrite this transformation as
t
of
x 1
x 2
is equal to
2 x
1 minus x 2 comma let me scroll over a
little bit
comma 3 x 1 plus 4 x 2. so hopefully
you're satisfied now that a matrix
multiplication it isn't some new exotic
form of trans transformation that they
really are just another way that this
this statement right here
is just another way of writing this
exact transformation
right here now the next question you
might ask and i already told you the
answer to this at the beginning of the
video is is multiplication by a matrix
always going to be a linear
transformation and what are the two
constraints for being a linear
transformation
we know that the transformation of
two vectors
a plus b
the sum of two vectors should be equal
to the sum of their transformations
transformation of a plus the
transformation of b and then the other
requirement is that the transformation
of a scaled version of a vector
should be equal to a scaled version of
the transformation these are our two
requirements for being a linear
transformation so let's see if matrix
multiplication applies there and i've
touched on this in the past and i've
even told you that you know you should
prove it and
we already kind of i've already assumed
you know but i'll prove it to you here
because i'm tired of telling you that
you know you should prove it i should do
it at least once so let's see matrix
multiplication if i multiply
a matrix
a
times some vector x
we know that let's say let me write it
this way
we know that this is equivalent to i
said our matrix we could just write
let's say this is an m by n matrix we
can write any matrix as just a series of
column vectors so this guy could have n
column vectors so let's say it's v1
v2
all the way to vn column vectors and
each of these guys are going to have m
components
times
x1 x2 all the way down to xn and we've
seen this multiple multiple times before
this by the definition of matrix vector
multiplication is equal to
x1
times v1 that times that this scalar
times that vector plus x2 times v2
all the way to plus xn times vn this was
by definition of a matrix vector
multiplication
and of course this is going to and i did
this at the top of the video this is
going to have
right here this this vector is going to
be a member of r m it's going to have m
components so what happens if i take
if i take some
if i take some matrix a some m by n
matrix a
and i multiply it
times
i multiply it times the sum of two
vectors a
plus b
where so i could rewrite this as
this thing right here so my matrix a
times the sum of a plus b the first term
will just be a1 plus b1 second term is
a2 plus b2
all the way down to a n
plus
bn
this is the same thing as this i'm not
saying a of a plus b i'm saying a times
let me put it maybe i should put a dot
right there i'm multiplying the matrix
it's not i don't maybe i want to be
careful with my notation this is the
matrix vector multiplication it's not
some type of new matrix dot product but
this is the same thing as this
multiplication right here and based on
what i just told you up here which we've
seen multiple multiple times this is the
same thing
as
a1
plus b1
times the first column in a which is
that vector right there this a is the
same as this a so times v1 plus a2 plus
b2 times v2 all the way to
plus a n plus bn
times vn
all i did each the each xi term here is
just being replaced by a i plus bi terms
so if you so each x1 here is replaced by
an a1 plus b1 here so this is
this is equivalent to this
and then from the fact that we know that
well vector
vector multiple vector vector
products times scalars exhibit the
distributive property we can say that
this is equal to
this is equal to a1 times v1
let me actually write all of the a1
terms well let me write this a1 times v1
plus b1
times v1 plus a2 times v2 plus b2 times
v2 all the way to plus a n times vn
plus b
n times v n
and then if we just reassociate this if
we just group all of the a's together
all of the a terms together we get a 1
plus a sorry
a 1 plus let me write it this way a1
plus times v1 plus a2 times v2
plus all the way
a n times vn i just grabbed all the a
terms
we get that plus all the b terms all the
b terms i'll do in this color all the b
terms are like that so plus
b1 times v1 plus b2 times v2 all the way
to plus
bn times vn that's that guy right there
is equivalent to this statement up here
i just regrouped everything which is of
course equivalent to that statement over
there
but what's this equal to
this is equal to
this is equal to my vector
these these columns remember the column
for the matrix capital a so this is
equal to the matrix capital a
times
a1 a2 all the way down to a n
which was our vector a and what's this
equal to this is equal to plus
these v ones these are the columns for a
so it's equal to the matrix a
times my vector b
b1
b2 all the way down to bn
this is my vector
b
so we just saw that we just showed you
that if i if i add my two vectors a and
b and then multiply it by the matrix
it's completely equivalent to
multiplying each of the vectors times
the matrix first and then adding them up
so we've satisfied and this is for any
an m by n matrix so we've now satisfied
this first condition
right there
and then what about the second condition
and this one's even more straightforward
to understand
c times a one
so let me write this way if i want to
write or let me just the vector a
times sorry the matrix capital a times
the vector lower case a
let me do it this way because i want
times the vector
c lowercase a so i'm multiplying my
vector times the scalar first is equal
to
i can write my big matrix a i've already
labeled its columns it's v1
v2
all the way to vn that's my matrix a and
then what does ca look like
ca you just multiply that scalar times
each of the terms of a so it's
ca1 ca2 all the way down to c
a n and what does this equal we we know
this we've seen this this show multiple
times before right there
so just equals
this equals i'll write a little bit
lower it equals c a one
times
this column vector times v one
plus
c a two times
v
two times this sky all the way
to
plus
c
a n
times v n
times v n
times the vector v n and if you just
factor this c out once again scalar
multiplication times vectors exhibits
the distributive property i believe i've
done a video on that but it's very easy
to prove so this will be equal to c
times i'll just stay in one color right
now a1 v1 plus
a2 v2
plus all the way to
a n
vn and what is this thing equal to well
that's just
our matrix a that's just our matrix a
times our vector
or our matrix uppercase a maybe i'm
overloading the letter a and then my
matrix uppercase a times my vector
lowercase a
times
my lowercase a right
where the case a is just you know this
thing right here a1 a2 and so forth this
thing up here was the same thing as that
so i just showed you that what if i take
my matrix and multiply it times some
vector that was multiplied by a scalar
first that's equivalent to first
multiplying the matrix times the vector
and then multiplying by the scalar
so we
we've shown you
that matrix
times vector products or matrix vector
products satisfy this condition of
linear transformations and this
condition
so the big takeaway right here is matrix
multiplication and this is a important
takeaway
matrix
matrix multiplication
or matrix products
with vectors
vectors
is
always
a linear transformation
linear transformation and this is a bit
of a side note in the next video i'm
going to show you that any linear
transformation this is incredibly
powerful can be represented by a matrix
product or by by any transformation on
any vector can be equivalently i guess
written as a product of that vector with
a matrix
as huge repercussions and you know just
as a side note kind of tying this back
to your everyday life you probably you
know you have your your xbox or your
sony playstation and you know you have
these 3d graphic programs where you're
running around and shooting at things
and the the way that the the software
renders those programs where you can see
things from every different angle you
know you have a cube and then if you if
you kind of move this way a little bit
the cube will look more like this and it
gets rotated and you move up and down
these are all transformations of
matrices and we'll do this in more
detail that and or these are all
transformations of of of vectors or the
positions of vectors and i'll do that in
a lot more detail and all of that is
really just matrix multiplications so
all of these things that you're doing in
your fancy 3d games on your xbox or your
playstation they're all just matrix
multiplications i'm going to prove that
to in the next video and so when you
have these graphics cards or these
graphics engines all they are and this
is kind of a you know we're jumping away
from the theoretical but all these you
know graphics processors are
are
hardwired matrix multipliers if i have
just a generalized some type of cpu i
have to in software write how to
multiply matrices but if i'm right
making an xbox or something and 99 of
what i'm doing is just rotating these
these abstract objects and and
displaying them in transformed ways
i should have a dedicated piece of
hardware a chip that all it does it's
hardwired into it is multiplying
matrices and that's what those graphics
processors or graphics engines really
are